so I'm going to yeah I'm going to talk
about um arithmetic circuits and some
results on how you obtain lower bonds
for how you prove yeah lower BS or how
you find hard function for this classes
of
circuit so the well it's not the talk is
not is not meant to be like a full list
of all the techniques that exist to
prove lower bonds for the circuit that I
will introduce I will mostly cover some
work that I've done with Stefan mangel
uh yeah two years ago
yeah so before yeah the first step is
obviously to describe what I mean by
arithmetic circuits and more precisely
what I mean by tractable arithmetic
circuits and so that we are all clear
about what we are talking about the
arithmetics one arithmetic circuits
first we'll see the tractable after so
an arithmetic circuit for me is just a
computational it's yeah a
computational graph that look like this
right so you got a single output you get
um a single output gate your inputs are
labeled by Boolean literals so which
will be zero one variable here we don't
go with minus one plus one it's Z one
and your your Gates compute operation so
we get the product and the and the plus
operation and an additional feature is
that for your for your plus gate there
input connectors are weighted by some
real
numbers and these can be negative and
this will be
important uh good so it mean that some
plus gates are actually Computing
subtraction and not
addition so these objects are so this
these are models for representing
through the buan function so boan input
real number
output and they have been studied under
different names like plus times programs
so arithmetic circuit is the one I'm
using some product networks I think you
need some other property but that's yeah
so different names in the literature for
this will be arithmetic
circuits and in this talks all the
arithmetic circuits will represent non-
negative functions because we we want
them to we want to use them to represent
probabilistic circuits so it makes no
sense if they can return negative value
however even though they represent non
negative function they can use negative
weight that's fine if they don't use
negative weight then we usually them
monoton arithmetic circuits but it is
known that if you allow negative weights
so if you allow subtraction in your
circuit then you can there are some
function which you can represent uh very
compactly but um in yes in new
arithmetic circuits but as soon as
you as you disable the negative weights
you're only allowing positive ones then
you get exponential size so since we
will want to find lower bonds
exponential lower Bond it makes sense to
Target already the most compact class of
circuits so we keep the negative weight
as much as
possible now an arithmetic circuit well
if it represents probability
distribution you may want to have a few
question we may want to to answer a few
problems and some queries on the on the
circuit and things like Computing
marginal probabilities Computing maximum
a posterior all of this is hard
generally but if you
if you put some properties on your
circuits uh some restriction on the
circuit then then many of these CES can
be can become tractable and so these
circuits I gather them under the name of
tractable arithmetic circuit which is a
gener very generic term not precise at
all just to uh say that these will be
circuits that respect a certain
combination of properties which I'm
going to describe right now so the first
one is mandatory it's the
decomposability
um so it's a it's a property on the
product gate so for convenience I we
assume that all the gates here are
binary and so the decomposability we've
heard about it already so for all for
all product Gates so product gate comput
C1 time C2 is the composable if the V
the C1 and C2 are working on D joint
dint on D joint stes sets of variables
so that so here all the product gate are
decomposable so I would call it a DE
posible
AC so like this one the first circuit it
works on X1 X2 the second circuit is
working on S3 S4 X5 so that D joints
good so that's also called syntactical
multi linearity and in fact it's a
syntactical property if I give you an
arithmetic circuit you can check in poom
time it's D composable that's not
problem the second property on the other
hand is semantical determinism and that
one is a property on the on the plus
gate it's saying that whenever I have um
a plus gate that comput C1 plus
C2 weighted
ter well these circuit C1 C2 have
disjoint support now the support of a
circuit is the set of Truth assign of
assignment of its variable such that the
circuit returns a nonzero
value uh so D joint support uh for the
two input circuits mean that for any for
every assignments to the variable one of
the two input will zero at least one
maybe both of them will but at least one
will good and there are other kind of
property that we can add just there is
smoothness which I'm not going to
describe we can often take it for
granted the one that is very important
for this talk is this one the structure
de composability so we've heard about
structure decomposable circuits
already in this program and uh it has
not really been defined so I'm going to
do it here because it's important for me
so it's a kind of restricted
decomposability so with de composability
your product gates are all they're all
splitting the variables in in some way
right you cannot have shared shared
variables between the subcircuits in
structure decomposability that's also a
kind of decomposability but the
separation between the variables you're
not allowed to do to do all the
separation you want they have to have to
be consistent with some structure which
is given to you and which we and which
is a branch de composition
over the the circuit variable so we call
it a variable tree or V tree just a
binary tree like this F leaves are in
dejection with the circuit variables no
I say that this circuit is structur the
composable and respect this vory if I
can do the following if I can color
every um every um product gate in my
circuits in such in the follow in the
following way so these two prod gates
are color I and blue because they are
both separ separate splitting X1 from X2
and this is exactly what this no is
doing good these two I color orange
because they are both separating X3 from
X4 which is what this node is doing in
the V3 and the last two they are both
separating X1 X2 from X3 X4 which is
what this red node is doing in the V3 so
if I can do this coloring in a way so if
I can do this coloring that is
consistent with the V3 then I say that
my arithmetic circuit is structur
decomposable and that it respect uh this
V3 yeah so yeah so just just one slide
just to say that
um so these two things are really yeah
so some arithmetic circuits they are
decomposable but you will they are not
structurely composable sometimes you
just can't find a a v3e mean all
function you can always you can always
find an arithmetic circuit which is
structure the composable but you may but
you can also find some that are
decomposable but not structured by any V
tree you just have to find two nodes
that split your variables in ways that
so that it would not be possible to find
a single V tree that will take into
account these two these two particular
splits so yeah basically the structure
decomposable AC are a strict uh subass
of the decomposable AC
that's good so so these the arithmetic
circuit these are you you have some
combination of De composability
determinism sometimes you have structure
de composability instead of of Baner de
composability but that's what I mean by
tractable arithmetic circuits and now
well since these circuits are well very
useful to answer a bunch of problems and
queries uh on the function
represented well obviously you expect
that for some functions it will be the
size of the of this of the tractable
circuit will be exponentially large so
you want to you expect some lower bonds
you expect some function would be hard
for this classes of circuits and so now
I'm going to show how we can find such a
such such hard functions the first uh
the first technique that you can use is
well what I call the boring trig because
I don't find it very interesting but
um the thing that I'm actually more
familiar with B circuits and with the
ones that are tractable so the ones that
respect the composability determinism
and so on and well if you it would be
convenient if we could just reduce our
tractable arithmetic circuits to the
tractable buan circuits and of course we
can do this we just take the the plus
gate we replace by or we we get rid of
the weights the product will replace by
end and assuming my initial circuit was
only using positive
weight
then this arithmetic circuits I've after
the transformation I've obtain a Boolean
circuit that represent this uh this
function so the indicator for the
support of the function so maybe you
have this circuit had no uh had no
assignment that's return zero in the
first place so this is just Computing
the uniform one function but sometimes
this will
not and so as you do this well the
composability is Reserve determinism to
and you end you end up in this class of
BU circuits which I'm not going to
describe and which are quite well known
we know a lot of hard function for this
so if you want to find a hard function
for your arithmetic circuit you just
take a hard bullan function you try to
and you say okay that's boan so that's
also Sudan I can try to represent it in
this way and because they are hard for
the for the tractable boan Circle it
will also be hard for the tractable
arithmetic circles now the problem with
this is that
well you need positive weights and we
don't want this uh yeah as soon as you
have negative weights here this
operation means that the function that
you will get is not the indicator for
the support yes use a weight even if
they positive where do they show up in
your trick
sorry even when you have weights and
they are positive where do they show up
in this
translation no they don't show up we
remove them
okay so you don't care about them
they're basically one yeah they become
one we don't care about them so so they
you comput a different a different
function yeah yeah uh this was a sud fun
this was representing a sud function
this and no the B this represent this B
function a function yeah yeah it's a
different function but if this one is
hard for this class of circuit then the
thing that you were trying to represent
in the first place is hard for your
arithmetic
circuit but you need the positive
weights and uh we yeah well you need the
positive weight only in but not in all
settings like in particular if your
arithmetic circuit is deterministics
then it's not so hard to prove that you
can just always assume that your weights
are already positive like if I give you
an arithmetic circuit and I tell you
it's
deterministic okay then it's it's
Computing the same function as this one
where I replace the weight by absolute
value
in addition you can also use determinism
if you have both determinism
decomposability and integer weight then
not only can you compute bullan uh
bullan circuits for this function but
you can also compute bullan circuits for
this function for any constant K you can
find a lot you can compute a lot more uh
tra tractable ban circuits in polinomial
time so you have a lot more candidate
bullan functions which could could be
hard for your buan
circuits yeah well this would generally
be tractable without this
termism but
still uh still uh we are not satisfied
if you don't have determinism you still
need positive weights and that's not
good so now I'm going to present another
techniques which is a rank technique and
for the and this one does not require uh
positive weights and this one we use to
to prove lower Bonds on the size of
structured the composable arithmetic
circuit you remember I have my V3 I want
to color my my gate so now this is we
want to prove for these
things and so the rank technique
um yeah so the rank technique will use
the lower bonds will be the rank of some
of some Matrix which I'm going to Define
and which I call the value Matrix I
think there all name probably but I like
to call it this way so I just I I give
an example in a second but I will just
need a partition a b part A B partition
of my
variable and yeah so I will I will
something like this so here you have an
example function never mind what it
represents it's a bit random and okay
five variables and I decided to
partition my variable in the following
way X1 X2 X3 in the first part X4 X5 in
the second part now the value Matrix for
this partition pi and for this function
f is defined as follow
so each col uh each column is uh
represent an assignment to the to the
variables in the first part of the
partition each row represents an
assignment to the variables in the
second part of the partition and now if
I look at a cell in my um in my Matrix
then it corresponds to one assignment to
the first part an assignment to the
second part and the content of the cell
is just the value of the of the
the value of the function add this
Global assignment to the
variable if your function was boan then
you will obtain only a bunch of one and
zero in here and we could you could call
this a communication Matrix or you could
just see it as a true stable or carob or
whatever uh yes just just one comment
the the the order of the rows and of the
columns is not important for us we going
to take the rank of that thing and the r
the rank is invariant
under permutation of columns and
rows good and so the the theorem is that
okay so you if you give me a V3 so
remember that thing on a partition of
the V of the variables that is induced
by the V tree which I'm going to Define
in a few second then every structure DEC
composable arithmetic circuits that
respect this V Tre and that represent
some function f will contain at least
this many gates the rank of the Matrix
function for this partition induced by
the V tree now what does it means for a
partition to be induced by a v tree well
it mean that I can obtain the partition
in the following way I pick an edge in
the V3 I removed
it uh and then I obtain two connected
two connected trees and the variable in
the first part will be the first part of
the partition the variable in the second
part are the second part of the
partition so in this examp for in this
example the partition X1 X2 X3 on one
side X4 X5 on the other size is induced
by this V3 so if I were trying to
represent this function as a structure
decomposable arithmetic circuits
respecting this V3 then I would sorry
there then I know that the rank of this
Matrix is a is a lower bound on the
number of gates I we need in my uh in my
circuit now it may not seem very
impressive but remember that you got as
many columns as you have uh TR
assignment and many as many rows as as
you got TR assignment on the second part
of your partition so this Matrix can be
exponentially large and it will yeah it
is exponentially large and so you could
have exponential Rank and so that's and
that's what we want we want exponential
lower Bond so that's what we are going
to that's where we are going
to uh yeah so in part so yeah a COR is
that if you don't fix the VRI uh you say
okay I'm I'm I'm representing my
function as a structure decomposable
arithmetic circles I'm not telling you
the V Tre then I can say okay no problem
this thing is lower B than the number of
of gates you will need the minimum of
all the possible rank of all possible
partitions but we restrict to the
partition that are balanced so meaning
that you got at least one third of the
variable in in in the first part of the
partition and also one third of the
variable in the second part you can
always find the balance partition for
every any V
tree okay so now our goal is to find the
functions for which this thing is
exponential in the number of variables
and well we found some uh so this is an
example of hard
function so this function will have some
underlying graph called so simple graph
no paral no parallel Edge no directed
Loop call it G and we have this thing so
the vertices corresponds to the V Ables
and whenever you have an edge
IJ in your in your graph then you you
multiply by one plus maximum of V of of
the yeah maximum of the two
variables so you can not F that yeah
this thing is never going to take value
zero so if I were to do the the boring
trick to reduce to a tractable bullan
circuits I will get a circuit that is
uniformly once very really not
interesting but what but uh it's very
good to apply the the rank l b
techniques because we can prove that if
G is an expander graph so that's a kind
of graph that is I'm not giving the
definition but it's a very well
connected graph and it's very well
connected and can have a can have a very
small degree so that's this D equal
constant then if G is an expanded graph
you can prove that this function for any
Balan partition of its uh of its
variable then you got this uh this
exponential L Bond on the on the size of
the rank good it means this thing is
exponential is the number of variables
for these
functions for exp for expand the graphs
and so since you have infinite class
infinite classes of expander graphs
which are regular in fact uh then then
that's it you you find an infinite class
of functions that can only be computed
by structured a composable arithmetic
Circuit of exponential size
size and at no point I've have I made I
I've never made any assumption on the
weights that I needed to to use for to
prove this lower Bonds in fact I can use
positive weights negative weight doesn't
matter you get exponentially many gates
in the end so that's nice now the
interest the most interesting part I
think but also the most complicated is a
proof to get uh to is a proof of this
theorem here yeah so just one word on
the proof
so it's the proof uses yeah you required
first to do some analysis on your
circuits to decompose your circuit as a
sum of um of decomposable product which
uh so if you're familiar with what with
how you obtain um circuit lower bond for
dnf circuits in the Boolean
World these things will correspond to
combinatorial rectangles but here they
would I would like to call them
arithmetic rectangles perhaps and anyway
that's this thing then you then you then
you prove that these functions have a
have have have value Matrix of of rank
one and then you use that the rank is
sub addtive and you obtain your your
lower bonds the
theorem so anyway there is some
interesting part which is hidden
here okay so now what I wanted to do to
to finish is to is to is to show um to
give an application of um of this result
um this will be a theoretical
application but still I find it quite
interesting so I'm going to use this
thing to prove a separation between
classes of tractable a arithmetic
circuits because you may you remember
I've said that the not all the
composable arithmetic circuit are
structure DEC composable in fact you may
Wonder well perhaps the arithmetics um
all decomposable arithmetic circuits you
can make them structure decomposable
without increasing the size too much and
so you would have structure de
composability for free and that's not
true you can prove that uh you have a
separation so a class of function that
will have smaller DEC composable
arithmetic circuits but that will only
have exponential size structure DEC
composable arithmetic
circuits now how can we prove this well
we need two we need a few things
um we need this uh we need to manipulate
a little arithmetic circuits in in
particular we need to be able to do
conditioning so it's just you have a
partial assignments on your variables
and well you haven't structure de
composable metic circuit if you assign
the bunch of variables then you obtain
uh then your circuit is still structur
de composable that's that's just what we
need yeah right if you're structured by
a V3 assign some variable you're still
structured by the same V3
and also an important uh an important
result is that if you if you give me two
arithmetic circuits that are structured
by the same V tree then I can obtain
another arithmetic circuit that is also
structured by the same V3 and that
represent the product of my of my two
inputs now if you want to take the
product by just putting a product gate
and putting your two circuits as a
children well your product gate is not
decomposable so we don't really care
about the that thing but if you two if
you two if you two input circuits are
respect the same VRI then you have a
quadratic time algorithm that will uh
merge them in some way and you will
obtain something that in the end is
structur De
composable in addition to this you we
want I will need some knowledge about
expand the graph and I will need the
following thing which is
that okay
so we're going to take a we're going to
look at the graph of n vertices and
which made in a particular way I'm going
to take a fixed path on the vertices
first okay so so just a straight line
and then so that will be graph G1 and G2
will be just a random pass on the
vertices so we got n factorial of them
and you take it uniformly at random and
then you define G1 o plus G2 as follows
you take G2 you put it on top of G1 and
you get rid of of the parallel edges so
the edge that was here since it's also
here you you don't have it in the in the
resulting graph so that this is this is
not a multi graph but three but three
simple graph and know I claim and I'm
not going to prove it but I claim that
it's true I mean done the
proof that if you choose G2 uniformly at
random then this graph here it's an
expander with high
probability and not only is it an
expander but it's easy to see that all
the vertices here have degree at at most
two atmost two as as well so everyone
here has degree atmosphere so that's an
expand graph with a with a with a small
degree
good and so yeah I just rewrite the hard
function here I said that FG is the
product of for every
Edge one
plus
okay
so I've so so so I've told you earlier
that when G in is an expand graph that
function is hard for structure the
compos for structure the composable
arithmetic circuit so with high
probability on the choice of G2 that
things admits only exponential size
structure the composable arithmetic
circuits but then then there is then you
can observe that this function
here actually the
product of these two fun of these two
function here well that's not quite true
actually uh you need a a subgraph of G1
because of the parall edges so that you
need to remove but for Simplicity you
can just assume that this is the
case um okay so what the but then what
does it mean if if you had if you could
represent that
thing as a structure de composable as a
circuit that is structured by some V3 T
that thing by the by the circuit that is
structured by some by the same V3 T well
they have the same V3 the same V3 so I
can take their their product in in
quadratic time and I will
obtain something that is structured and
that represent this function this has to
be exponentially large so one of this
has to be exponentially large at least
one so for all T either this is
big or this is bigger one of the two has
to be large maybe both of them are but
at least
one
okay
however you could you could chose uh if
you're allowed if you're allowed to
choose different
Vries then you can find a first circuit
that represent this one which is small
another circuit that represent this
function and that is also small it's
possible because they respect different
Vries it's fine
and now you're going to use this to to
uh you're going to use this this to to
to to construct uh your hard your
functions to the function to do the
separation essentially you're going to
use this so you
introduce a fresh variable Y and you
just
create and you look at this
function well I claim that that's thing
as a small admit small decomposable
arithmetic circuits that's quite easy to
see you just take a plus gate top you
have a product gate
here and then you put the small circuit
for your fun for function
fg1 and on the other
side you put the small function for fg2
so this is the comp this is the
composable this is the composable the
whole thing is the composable it is it
is a small circuit it's not structured
and of and of course it's it's not
structured because if you were to try to
represent that function as a structure
the composable arithmetic circuit then
you have some problem which is that if
you condition the if you condition your
function of on y on y equal one you end
up with with a circuit that is
structured that represent this if you
condition it on y equal zero then you
obtain a circuit that is a circuit that
is structured by the same V Tre and
represent this guy
and since the circuit you will obtain by
doing this conditioning respect the same
V3 you know it has to be you know it has
to be large so that mean that the your
initial circuit that was structur
composable and representing this thing
is exponentially large and that's it
that give you uh that gives you the
separation you have a class of functions
which are easy to represent as de
composable arithmetic circuit very hard
to represent a structure de composable
arithmetic circuits
and again I never had to assume anything
about uh about weights being positive or
negative they can be negative it doesn't
matter the separation will
hold
good uh yeah so I've been quite fast
actually yeah so that's it so that's all
uh I wanted to present so the arithmetic
circuits the obvious rediction to to BU
circuit which work only in some settings
but you can find some
techniques that will work in the in the
settings where you have negative weights
and once you find a result you can you
can always use it to to prove some
separation between classes of arithmetic
circuit there are still some separation
that we don't that I don't know about so
there are still a lot of um open
question on tractable arithmetic
circuits when you have the negative
weights otherwise we sort of know how to
to analyze them good thank
[Applause]
you are there any
questions yeah thank thank you for the
nice talk um I have a question about the
rank serem where you can prove low BS on
the rank y do you need struct structure
there I mean can't you prove some kind
of similar results if you don't have
structure uh okay so if I don't have
structure I can go here so I
can uh so basically if I don't have
structure I will find the decomposition
of my circuit as a
sum of rectangles I mean you know
what of these things but here you will
not have the same partition necessar I
mean you will have different
partition and then if you then you how
do you I mean
here I can just take I can just say that
I take the Matrix of this thing for a
given
partition and and then just say that
the yeah so
that's no you're right okay it's it was
me being stupid no sorry yes no no no I
guess
get that's
um you yeah you will not be able to to
to to just say that that this is the sum
of your Matrix if they do not if they do
not have the
different partition you may have
different dimension of the Matrix and is
yeah yeah of course yeah sorry thank you
so yes for for decomposability only we
are stuck here we don't know how to and
we don't know how to prove Bonds in
these settings is not the same as
combinator rectangle
yeah yeah so um regarding this this
result which is very very nice uh so the
Matrix you described to us is
essentially a much higher order tensor
but you reduce it to a matrix have you
looked can you derive anything
interesting by looking at the entire
tensor to examine its rank as opposed to
um collapsing it down to a
matrix not very well
inow on R is much harder than proving
this kind
of so I mean there is a paper byas where
he Associates size of arithmetic
formulas with t
RS and this is this is similar Techni I
can give
point and basically I mean he he has
some results the conclusion of the paper
is that it is impossible to prove any
lower B so this
is the
connection
what's the complexity of finding a good
upper bound or approximating the rank
for a given um
formula the complexity of finding a hper
b yeah I'm I'm thinking can we also flip
it to have some upper bound you guide
the design of a compiler
also if I know the rank is going to be
high for this given partition then why
do why you try
well how would you know that the rank is
High I mean that's an exponential size
Matrix you're not going to compute that
thing no no but do we have to compute is
there a way to get an upper bound
without having to compute The Matrix
oh I was say you can use intermediate
step no no I don't know I have no no I
don't know
maybe we have not thought about this
sorry thank you for the talk those of us
who have been here since August in the
program have been exposed to um a lot of
material about semi rings so suppose we
take the arithmetic circuit and instead
of thinking of numbers we have values
from a semi ring and the Plus in the
time of the semi ring that's still a
circuit to compute something what
happens to the technique with the
rank metrics do have people looked at
such things
and suppose I had the tropical s meing
so the plus mean and times is plus yeah
so um okay so before that so I for I
forgot to forgot to tell it but the the
rank technique it's it's known already
for in communication complexity for boan
anyway so that that's not completely new
but then if you have if you have a
suing
but the thing is that we sort of use
here that the that the rank is sub
additive
to
yeah we need to we need to express our
circuit as this sum here and since this
sum is a sum of our real numbers we can
use that that's the rank uh is
subjective to say that if we put a um
the rank
of a mat of a sum of matrix it's fewer
than it's fewer that the sum of the rank
of the Matrix but I if you change
shimmering I will assume that this sum
would not have the same meaning and the
rank would still have to be sub additive
for this new sum in your in your for the
sum of your
suing what I
mean and so I I don't really know how
this uh I don't I don't know of any
other of the of what other works have
done maybe they they managed to do it
but I will not find a way to directly
adapt these techniques to any other
sing probably very silly question but
why are you interested in negative
weights you know I'm forance from
machine learning probabilistic reasoning
for us the weights are probabilities so
are always non negative why why because
uh because when you have negative
weights you can you can represent thing
much more
compactly and so we are trying to find
lower bonds for the thing that we know
are the are the best to to uh to
represent and yeah that's the only
reason like we
um
if we could um we could restrict to
positive weight we will have a lot of
results and we have a lot of result for
positive ways but so we are not
exploiting the
full capabilities of the arithmetic
circuits
Pro if you prove something for yeah we
prove something for for the we try to
prove lower bonds for the strongest
possible class for probabilistic
circuits it would be interesting Al to
find if if you have an equivalent model
with negative weights to find an
interpretation of these negative numbers
a lot of interest in negative
probabilities in Quantum
information
yeah but this more tricky but maybe also
with standard say real valued
probabilities I don't
know
questions thank you so much for the talk
um I was wondering if you could say a
little bit more about um how you get the
uh indicator function greater than equal
to K for deterministic and decomposable
circuits the K yeah with the K yeah that
thing so we need integer
weights okay let's
see so you want to know when it's
deterministic yeah so for deterministic
unless I'm
mistaken uh if you want just
to suppose you want only the the the the
the values that are returned by these
things such that you uh that are greater
than than some okay we'll say k here
well you just uh you will just need to
find the one that are greater than K in
in both children because you know
anyway if you got greater than K here
since one of them is has to be zero
always so it's so for the for the
product nodes okay for the product no
then weights you can kind of so for the
product so that's actually the thing
that that you cannot do with just the
with determinism for the product you
just oh no no no sorry I'm that's I
can I that was right okay
time alha uh so here you you want
greater than uh than say k minus L and
here you
want well perhaps equal L something like
this and so you need um basically you
need to you need to create one new one
new node per uh per value between zero
and between zero and K and you would
obtain something so that's still this
time this product is decomposable
because this one was the
composable um you will get that this is
deterministic if uh because all the this
one so if you you got another one here
for B beta and you only take the
assignment that's return value L Prime
well you
cannot well does it work I yes I think
it
does yeah yeah yeah beta cannot return
both l and an L Prime at the same time
so this if this is not zero this will be
zero so one of the two will be zero and
you have you have a lot of K as many as
you have L's between between the z z and
K so you will need to create uh K copy
of every of every node in your original
circuit and so if K is constant which
I'm assuming because if K is not conent
I can prove it's not it's not possible
then uh then it's fine you got you got a
pomal Time
transformation yeah that makes sense
thank
you did you have a question
so I actually have a stupid question so
at some point you showed that for
deterministic circuits you can just take
like the the absolute values of the
weights but I didn't get like are you're
saying they will have the same value or
that you can build a circuit with the
I'm saying that if your circuit has a
had a minus as a negative weight you can
remove the minus and that's that's the
same circuit that's the same fun that's
the same function that is computed by a
circuit of the same
size just one node one plus node with
just one minus value of a weight circuit
is is Computing a non negative function
that's I said it in the beginning but I
should have stressed it at that point
yes that's that's why it works okay
otherwise it's it's not otherwise I
don't I don't no otherwise it would be h
have to remove the negative way I guess
because they're Computing non- negative
function because we want them to to
represent probability distribution
potentially not
normalized uh but then put yeah non
negative function so we can remove the
the negative weight that's the reason
right no more
questions okay so let's thank the
speaker
again okay so let's was the last of
today um the idea is that we now we have
a